joli raté ça brille avec le soleil c'est
grand c'est bon tu vas me faire acheter
ta place aussi bien sûr qu'est ce tu
crois je savais pas que c'était devenu
raide
elle a fait fortune comment va la
famille ça va bien surtout quand vous
vois pas comment elle est belle la
chance à jacky d'avoir un moment aussi
gentil cadors sa famille de foot bien
sûr qu'il est bon les a ni si jamais tu
as besoin d'argent prix n'hésite pas on
nous en demande et entend battre avec
plaisir un shérif tout leur prête à voir
en fait non mais moi j'ai pas besoin de
toi et aimar et des piles ou jules
baudou - alors on fait quelque chose
tout laisse nous insulter c'est ta soeur
corrige la d'être aussi tu vas judo m'a
peut-être je vais y aller avec mon frère
non avec lui serait de l'argenterie
foutu en l'air qui se mariera avec la
colonelle et vous vous allez rester ici
non ce qui risque d'arriver c'est que
nous on ira au palais à fontaine avec
vergeot et que fauves c'est les
résidences trop pourri